this is potsdamer platz as we now know
it
back in the 1920s this intersection was
already a hive of activity until bombs
pounded into rubble in the Second World
War then it became a wasteland in the
middle of a divided city when the Berlin
Wall went up in 1961 potsdamer platz
became part of a closely watched
no-man's land known as the death strip
the first segments of the wall were
removed two days after it fell in 1989
people poured across the open border
rebuilding began in 1994 potsdamer platz
became Europe's biggest construction
site
the revamp took about six years
the area was now home to
state-of-the-art skyscrapers designed by
a host of internationally renowned
architects from henwood Yan and Hans
Koloff to thenso piano the gap between
East and West Berlin was closed but
stahma Platz became a symbol of the new
reunited city
[Music]
a ribbon of cobblestones marks the route
to where the wall used to stand little
else remains of the past a few segments
of the wall are on display flanked by
information panels
[Music]
I think they could be more considering
how historic it was like I really loved
the pieces of the wall but I think it
should stand out more I think
there needs to be more appreciation of
its historical significance in ink
it's got explanations which are very
very interesting and very useful to
visitors such as myself have never been
to Berlin before glass steel and
concrete potsdamer platz is once again
an impressive hub in central Berlin